rachel claude a toujours pensé faire sa
vie en ville on sort beaucoup lé dans
les restaurants les bars mais les longs
mois de confinement et le télétravail
ont changé les plans
présentement on travaille dans la
cuisine ou dans la salle à manger
donc on n'a pas vraiment bureau on a pas
vraiment d espace puis ça
faire rendre compte aussi que d'acheter
un trou ennemi ou un cat ennemis à
verdun ça serait pas assez pour six ont
continué comme ceux dans la prochaine
année travaillée de la maison donc on se
pensait confédérés vers la réussite
passe un petit peu moins dispendieux et
rachel est loin d'être la seule
interrogés sur leur intention de quitter
ou non la métropole 40 2 % des
montréalais répondent qu'il est probable
qu'ils aillent vivre ailleurs
ce chiffre grimpe à 56 % chez les 18 34
ans 42% c'est majeur les résultats ont
de quoi étonner dit le responsable du
sondage la pandémie ce qu'elle a fait
c'est pas la cause fondamentale c'est
pas la motivation la pandémie c'est un
déclencheur c'est un détonateur
si la pandémie est l'élément déclencheur
c'est le prix du logement qui fait fuir
les montréalais 76% pensent déménager
pour payer moins cher c'est vraiment le
pays personnellement moi mon copain on
n'a pas envie non plus d'aller acheter
une première propriété qui va nous
mettre la plane le couteau à la gorge
la mère de rachel n'est pas surprise par
la décision de sa fille ma fille qui
voulait rien savoir la hume sud
maintenant on cherche que la elle-même
courtière en immobilier micheline
lapierre voit plusieurs montréalais se
ruer présentement vers les maisons de
banlieue vous dis un engouement terne
s'est jamais vu autant de gens de
montréal a acheté soleil et puis aussi
les gens qui veulent aussi s'éloigner
qui s'en vont aussi vers les cantons de
l'est
parmi tous ceux qui songent quitter la
ville la moitié se tourner vers la
campagne hors du grand montréal à cause
du télétravail tout a changé
maintenant il regarde plus du tout la
même catégorie de maisons ils peuvent
s'éloigner un peu plus s'est fait casser
c'est ça vaut beaucoup d'options chaque
année environ 20000 montréalais quittent
la ville au profit des banlieues un
phénomène récurrent toujours compensées
par les naissances et surtout la venue
de nouveaux arrivants il ya un siècle le
problème effectivement c'est que le
robinet qui alimente le cycle lui est
fermé présentement beaucoup moins 10
milliards qui rendent sur montréal
puisqu'on ne sait pas c'est combien de
temps les frontières vont rester fermés
ici vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal